i knew you were no way home how i knew  how i was talking to this tom holland  guy tom's a really bad liar he is i love  you tom  the worst liar and we were talking about  zendaya's stunt where she has to jump  off scaffolding uh-huh and uh god and so  they was saying oh you know it was  exciting and i'm so looking forward to  do it and tom was like oh my god it  looks amazing i mean i wasn't there of  course  but that was quite a scary stunt yeah  what you guys did there yeah it was fun  it was really fun it's very annoying i  wasn't  well this is something and  [Music]  and i've actually  i screen grabbed the moment where you  can see his soul  leave  [Music]  ah  [Music]